we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
i don't like the voicemail i'm about to
play for you
i think the caller is calling me racist
uh a couple days ago i said
oprah
bears some responsibility for unleashing
dr oz mehmet oz onto the world
and this caller i think is saying i'm
racist for saying that
hello i'm
so confused with myself because i can't
believe i'm calling
but something you said really annoyed me
and to be honest i normally just ignore
these asides by um
certain demographics certain
demographics uh oh it sounds like
because i appear to be white
i said the wrong thing
because if they don't have black friends
or anything like maybe they just don't
get it well meaning as they might be
they might just say anyway
i was really surprised to hear you
um
use the
oprah thing and say the real question is
why oprah unleashed muhammad all into
the world blah blah blah and i realized
you said you were joking a lot of people
say that and then say they're joking
it's not a joke um
oprah is not responsible for anything to
do with these people and their views on
all of this
she had a production company i believe
and um hired people based on shows
that could make money nobody blames mark
burnett for
donald trump actually a lot of people do
a lot of people do a lot of people say
if mark burnett had never given trump
the apprentice
trump never would have become president
so that's wrong but listen here's the
thing guys oprah being black has nothing
to do with why i said she's responsible
for unleashing mem at oz
way before years before mehmet oz got
the dr uh oz show produced by oprah
oprah invited dr oz onto her show more
than 60 times okay so
it this has nothing to do with race and
of course if oprah invites someone 60
times and they have no popular appeal
they're not going to all of a sudden be
a viable senate candidate but oprah as
as she has launched the careers of many
people i mean listen oprah's responsible
for dr phil i would argue who by the way
is not a psychologist
um
uh
it
it's it has nothing to do with race
oprah's responsible for many people
being well known mehmet oz is one of
them dr phil mcgraw is another one of
them and that's it
uh it's i this is this is the exact you
know i say this stuff is not really
common on the left but sometimes you see
it
this is the stuff that just
i it's race related that i said
oprah's responsible for mehmet oz give
me a break guys give me a break it's not
uh this ain't it as the kids these days
like to say we have a great bonus show
for you today producer pat will be
making his triumphant return to the
bonus show after a few days off we are
going to talk about the horrible
shooting in the new york subway will
tell you what is now known
uh shanghai china residents
who are screaming from their windows
during lockdown are getting visits from
drones warning them about their behavior
and we will also talk about new
allegations that elon musk by delaying
the announcement of the stake he
purchased in twitter
saved a bundle on his taxes all of those
stories and more will be addressed in a
serious manner today on the bonus show
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at joinedpakman.com
don't miss it
and if you already have a membership you
can gift a membership gift a membership
at joinpakman.com
lastly tuesday april 19th at 6 00 p.m
we'll be doing the next david pakman
show viewer town hall everybody's
welcome to call in we'll be streaming
the town hall live on our second youtube
channel that's the pacman live youtube
channel hope to see you there and
remember that everybody's welcome to
call in but our website members will get
a priority line to call in
sign up at joinpacman.com